Today,
I want to talk to you about the incur and that amazing system of
numbers,
the largest utilization in the Americas before the arrival of the Europeans,
they peaked about the 16th century where the area covered by the Inca
empire started in Columbia in the North,
went all the way down to sort of bits of chili via Peru, Ecuador,
and Bolivia all in the NDAs. So that's about several thousand miles,
but it's about a million people.
So the ink is a really interesting because of the,
we call them bronze age civilizations.
They were the only one that didn't have certain important things,
which the other problems, age civilizations did. They didn't have a wheel.
And you can maybe explain that because, you know,
it's the Andes and wheels that are going to help you up a mountain.
They also didn't have a writing system,
but what they did have with this amazing system for recording
numbers, and they did this using knots on string,
the system is called Keepa or creepo sometimes it's Q U I P U
sometimes it's K H IPU. Um, I guess it's a,
it's a catch wild word catch world,
which incidentally is the indigenous American language still spoken by the
largest number of people. There's about, I think about 10 million people,
speakers of Quechua. And that was the language of the Incan empire. Anyway,
I have a hippo here.
This [inaudible] is a replica of one that is in the American museum of natural
history in New York. And keepers are bunches of strings.
They've got knots on, but there is some kind of method to them.
Often they work strings. Obviously this is some kind of colored lines.
They're not this type of string, but they all had a primary cord.
So that's the yellow ones. So that's the cord that doesn't have any knots on it,
but all the other ones hang off. It's like a massive kind of janitors.
Key-ring often there were hundreds of strings here.
I've only got five other strings and you've got these red ones are the strings
with the knots on.
And the green one is a certain string that links
this set of four.
So you see the green one links the set to four and the green one also has some
knots on.
And what I would like to do today is to explain to you how this
works,
but by replicating the original decipherment of keeper.
So it was in the 16th century that the inkers were conquered by
the Spanish and then knowledge amongst Europeans of how keepers works was
completely lost.
And it was only rediscovered in 1912 because a maths teacher could I called
Leslie Leland, Locke,
fantastically alliterative named Leslie Leland, Locke,
um, Matthew from Brooklyn and went to his local museum,
the American museum of natural history.
So this very hippo and worked out from the knots,
what it meant and how it worked.
And so why don't we go through what he would have done?
The first thing is let's look at each bit string.
So when you look at the string,
you see that it seems to be that there are three positions
and in each different position here, here, and here,
there are certain knots. So what I'm going to do, I'm just going to ride it out.
I going to say string one,
we're going to have position one position to position three.
So this is the first one. So in position one, we've got one position two,
we got three in position three, we've got.
Cool.
So already we get some kind of sense of what
this might be because all the numbers are quite low,
actually not going above six, which is kind of interesting.
So that might be the first clue that something is going on here.
And now let's just put a line here and let's do the green string.
So this is the green string. This is the string that links them all together.
So string five, I guess one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
actually that's eight first. Then there's a quite a big gap.
So that zero one, two, three, four, five, and that's five.
So Brady or maybe revenue, one watching this already.
You've got this.
Can you begin to see what the knots might be recording and what the relation
might be between these four strings,
the full red ones and the green one that links them together.
It's actually very simple, but if you didn't know it,
it's almost impossible was very,
very difficult to try and find out that's the intellectual efforts required
to decipher something. Cause you're not entirely sure what you're looking for,
but I've made it an incredibly simple because if you actually look here,
let's add these ones up for six,
five is 15. So five carry one,
three, six, five, five is 19 with that.
One carrier is 20 there, one, four,
five, six, seven, eight, eight.
So Leslie Lennon block realized that the answer was staring him in the face.
It was nothing more complicated that each string represents a single
number, a single three digit number. So the one that has one position,
one, three in position two and forms it.
Three is actually 134 because position one is the
hundreds position. Two is the tens and position three is the units.
The inkers, you know, they had this massive empire, 10, 12 million people.
They had bureaucracy, bureaucracy requires numbers and statistics.
So in a sense, the keepers which were used for, um,
census information for measurements, for money,
um,
such as the gel that glued his entire empire together and what you would have,
if you needed to record a number, you'd put this three digit number,
or it could be longer if you want, need more digits on each string.
And if you wanted to add them up to save, adding them up,
you would join them with another string. And that would be the sum.
So this is incredibly efficient. And in fact,
what they've done is they've kind of invented the decimal system without
realizing it, what they hadn't done there, wasn't a zero knots.
You have to realize there's a space there. So that could be quite confusing,
but they'd know they knew other things. So actually here,
I've done them all with the same note.
That's because I'm not very good at doing knots.
The way that the Indians did is that the last knots where it was slightly
different than a slightly longer knots.
And that's because a slightly longer night was always units.
So just say you had a piece of string that was came to attached or something.
You could look at it and you think, okay,
I know exactly the way this is going to go. I know to read it,
this is goes units, tens, hundreds, and so on.
It doesn't seem like it would have been the hardest thing to figure out,
like what, how could this be such a mystery for so long?
Well, it was figured out in 1912.
So the whole studying these civilizations was not very
developed. Also,
people were probably interested in other things about that society.
And there weren't that many keepers that you could go and have a look at.
Some of the keepers had hundreds of strings.
If you're going to be kind of pulling them apart,
it's quite hard to know where to look,
but also why would you even think that it was arithmetic in numbers,
even to think that it's much easier once you know that you could,
it could have been, it could have been anything else you could have thought, Oh,
this is something that's going from one to the three to the fruit.
It's getting bigger. There are lots of other patterns that you can see.
It could have been jewelry or headwear or something. Yeah.
Well, I think people knew that from studying it.
And obviously when they were conquered in the 16th century,
they didn't all die out. They kept on using it bits and bobs.
And also there were Spanish historians that came over and wrote about it and
said, it's well known that they had a sort of counting number system,
which was based on these, um, strings and knots. But yeah,
the proper decipherment was only made in 1912.
There are about a thousand hippies around in museums.
And a lot of still not known about them. It could be the case that some of them,
the knots actually represent phonetic elements.
So one of the great mysteries that people who look in cardiologists looking
at today is,
was the hippo more than just the inkers counting system,
but also some interesting new type of writings. Yeah.
This episode was supported by brilliant and it's ever expanding collection of
puzzles problems.
And in-depth courses have a look at some of this from their
scientific thinking course.
I wonder they call it brilliant. It's interactive. It's clever, it's fun.
It's like going to the gym for your brain,
but without all those sweaty changing rooms and stuff, by the way, brilliant,
doesn't have to be just for you.
Why not give brilliant as a gift to a friend or family member,
young or old who doesn't love,
upping their game and boosting their brain go to
brilliant.org/number file for more there's 20% of brilliance premium
subscription. If you use that URL there on the screen,
that gives you access to everything and our thanks to brilliant for continuing
to support number four,
Alex, this was so fascinating. Where could I read about this?
If you want to know more about that in my new book called the language lovers
puzzle book, I have a whole section on the hippo and on a bat,
the decipherment of it. In fact,
the book has lots of things just going to be about language,
but it's also about scientific language and mathematical notation.
And so you're going to learn about the history of mathematical notation.
Also in this book. I can't wait. I can't wait
Christmas. That's like what a great Christmas present. Hey. Yeah.
Especially in London.